the los angeles lakers are a game away
from their
17th nba championship they are so close
after beating the miami heat last night
magic johnson won five championships
during his legendary career with the
lakers
after retiring he created a business
empire he's doing very well he's the
chairman and ceo of magic johnson
enterprises
it's known for a wide range of
businesses from movie theaters to a
recent partnership
with hemp and cbd company uncle buds i
just like saying uncle buds
johnson is also the subject of an
upcoming docu-series about his life and
career
and just yesterday it was announced that
the director rick famous known for films
like
brown sugar and the wood will helm this
untitled project
so we spoke with magic johnson yesterday
about the nba finals
his successful business career and
working with family uh for the
docu-series
it's no surprise to anybody that there's
now going to be a documentary about your
life
how did that come about what happened
was you know after the success
of michael jordan's uh documentary then
everybody
start calling me up and say listen you
got a story too
so do you plan to be very hands on are
you gonna turn it over to rick
rick uh who i've known for a long time
excellent director i wanted to make sure
that
i had an african-american who understood
me he grew up watching the lakers
so he had a sense of me already i had a
sense of him already
i remember sports illustrated cover you
were 31 years old at the time and you
said then
i'm a big dreamer for some reason i'd
like to own an office building
when i was young about 14 15 years old
i ran into two african-american men who
lived in lansing michigan where i'm from
greg eaton and joel ferguson and they
they showed me that
we as minorities could own buildings so
my dreams
actually changed because of those two
guys
and so i also wanted to become a
businessman after
my career was done uh with the lakers
you know what irvin you were thinking
about brands
before people even thought about what a
brand was
so as we sit here today in 2020 what
does a magic johnson brand mean to you
well first of all i think it represents
all people it represents
giving back because i love to affect
change especially in urban america in
the inner cities how do i make the world
better
and i think that's what i would say my
brand stands for
do you have anything that you're excited
about right now there's
a few businesses that are really
exciting i mean
i got into uncle buds and it excites me
because of the fact that it has
you know uh cbd it really helps me in
terms of my pain relief
on uh as i gotten older it's harder for
me to recover from working out because
we should say you're not a doctor but
you're saying
this works for you i think it works for
me
and everybody's got to find what works
for them right and so
if you uh want to look it up look it up
and
do your homework do your research hey
irvin does it work on bad knees
i got some bad knees yes i got some too
that's why i use it
hey after after all those years on the
basketball court i take
any help i can get we must talk about
basketball for a second what do you
think is going to happen it seems to me
that it's almost preordained for the
lakers considering all that has happened
this year
to the laker family all season long
has been dedicated to winning the
championship especially once kobe passed
away so lebron's been focused
it is hard for me because i love pat
riley and if
miami was playing another team i would
be cheering for the miami heat
and pat riley he is a very very close
friend of mine
but you know circumstances hell when
you're playing against my lakers i can't
cheer against my lakers
miami is no joke though irvin miami is
no joke yeah miami is good
but i think that the lakers are a better
team and
uh and usually the better team wins
and i think the lakers will win uh
lebron is on a mission because he wants
his fourth ring
so there's a matchup between lebron
james and michael jordan who's winning
who's a better player in your opinion if
you're looking for a score it's going to
be michael jordan
right there's nobody that can compete
with michael scoring the basketball ever
but if you talk about all-around game
then you're talking about lebron james
now we gotta say michael jordan won six
championships
lebron is on his way to winning his
fourth so he's just got to catch him in
the championships
if he does that then watch out then he
can replace the king
the goat but the goat right now is still
michael jordan
the players took on a activist role
social justice they spoke up
after the shooting of jacob uh blake
they they announced a boycott
what did you think when you saw that
they had taken that action and decided
to boycott
yeah i was proud of not just the
nba players but also the nfl players the
wnba players to see them rally behind
george floyd and brianna taylor on and
on and on
has been good because black lives do
matter
yeah you know when you were a player the
story was rodney king and unfortunately
there's a story in the news today
jonathan price
in texas i just wonder how many more
times do we have to hear this story
gail you and i have been around long
enough to
understand that you know change has to
come
it's happening far too many times
we just want to make sure that all
people can have equal rights
all people can be safe when they leave
their home
and i just hope that we can end this one
day
we all wish that magic johnson i mean he
said even he still gets nervous when he
sees a police car and
we all know who he is but he's got such
a magnetic smile he's such a great human
being yes
on so many different levels one of the
things i said to him yesterday one of
the things i admire about you
is how much you love your wife cookie
they've been married for several years
and
his devotion to her he's loud and proud
and says she's a big part of the success
that he is today
so as for the game they can wrap it up
on friday
or they could wrap it up in game seven
but he says it's going to be wrapped up
with a lakers victory i love seeing his
love of the lakers yeah you know and how
deep it is and enduring it is
a special year for them and if lebron
catches jordan in championship
greatest of all time right